in this segment we want to reinforce the
message that how you choose to sample
can give different results and the
choice of sampling is important suppose
you're interested in measuring the
average family size in some population
suppose that there are families that are
small and have just one person in them
and there's also a family that has many
people in it what does it mean to
measure the average family size one
possibility is to pick at random a
family each family being chosen with
equal probability and talk about the
expected value that you get or the
average value if you sample that way in
this particular example with probability
1/4 you get the one with revealty 1/4
you get the one with probability 1/4 you
get a 1 so the answer would be with
probability 3/4 you get a 1 and with
probability 1/4 you get a 6 but suppose
that instead you pick a person at random
and you ask that person how big is your
family what's the expected value of the
answer you are going to get here we have
9 people out of those nine people three
of them will give you an answer my
family has size 1 and 6 of those people
will give you an answer my family has a
size of 6 and this number is going to be
larger than the previous number you're
going to get different answers so it is
possible to have a situation where you
can make a statement such as the
following the average family size is 3
but the average person lives in a family
of size 4 there is no contradiction
between these two statements because
we're measuring different things another
example of the same flavor you're
interested in the average bus occupancy
you're
interested in whether buses are crowded
or not in your city one way of carrying
out this calculation is to pick buses at
random each bus is equally likely to be
picked and see how many people are
riding this bus another possibility is
to take a typical passenger a random
passenger and ask them how crowded was
your bus take an extreme case suppose
that half of the buses have zero people
in them and half of the buses have 50
people in them if you look at random
buses then the average occupancy would
be 25 but if you ask passengers all of
the passengers would report 50 and it
would be again a different answer
a similar situation is if you are
talking about average class sizes one
method is to look at all the classes see
how many students there are in each
class and take the average another
method would be to ask a typical student
how large is your class because more
students are in large classes when you
pick a student at random you are likely
to get a higher answer as opposed to
when you look at a random class the
moral from all these examples is that it
is very important to be careful about
what you choose to sample when you pick
at random what exactly are you picking
at random and you need to be aware that
different sampling methods measure
different things and will generally give
you different results